more than a million rohingya refugees in
Cox's Bazaar depend on food and other
rations provided by the U.N and other
Aid agencies
the help has been vital for many here
like lalmia and his family members but
he is now worried about a recent cut to
Russians at a time when help is needed
the most
because of the new rationing we can't
get all the food items like we used to
it is now going to be difficult to
manage with so little
it's not just the cuts to Aid that's
worrying the rohingya community people
who live here set fire an incidence of
violence are becoming increasingly
frequent in the camp a large fire last
Sunday destroyed the makeshift homes of
more than 12 000 people
after fleeing the fire we came back to
rebuild our home right now our relatives
are bringing us some hot food it's a
hard time for us all name
is with the UN Refugee agency she says
the rohingya crisis is still an
emergency and needs extended funding
among the most interesting parts of this
joint plan is that we will be scaling up
the education the access to skill
development the access to even
livelihoods because we want refugees to
be more self-reliant to be able to
support each other to be part of their
response
many think the repercussion of this cut
will be immediate and long lasting cut
will definitely affect the ranger
community so when you'll go for ration
card that will affect the children
particularly who are you know below 18
years old suffering from malnutrition
the level will be going down further
down the rohingya refugees live in a
restricted environment with barbed wire
Fences Unlimited freedom of movement
outside the camp they don't have
opportunities for work access to formal
education or any hope of returning home
anytime soon
many are fleeing the camp for countries
like Malaysia seeking a better life this
often involves a dangerous and often
fatal Journey with the help of human
Smugglers
six years on the rohingya refugee crisis
is showing no sign of winding down the
repatriation process is nowhere in sight
and the management of more than million
refugees that Bangladesh is hosting is
becoming increasingly complex and
challenging San Andreas balukali